thank you for joining us America we give
you the same financial advisor
grandmother did only we keep our teeth
in Brian is with us in Chicago
hi Brian how are you I'm doing good Dave
how are you better than I deserve what's
up well I'm currently 17 years old I'm
working a part-time job right now and I
have saved up a little bit of cash just
under two grand and I was looking to
invest it in some like either in stocks
or in like cryptocurrencies I'm just
wondering what your painting is on
cryptocurrencies is it worth it or is it
not worth it well let's walk through how
that works and then maybe you can help
maybe you can come to the same
conclusion I have okay my friend rabbi
lapin who is a world-class economist who
wrote a book called thou shall prosper
says that money is spiritual and what he
means by that is money is all about
trust okay the if someone hands you a
green piece of paper with a president's
face on it and the number 100 on it and
you become convinced it is not a
counterfeit $100 bill you know you trust
with good reason that you can take that
somewhere and exchange it for goods or
services right yeah but it really
doesn't have any value it's a green
piece of paper
the only value it carries is the trust
that it carries do you see what I'm
saying yes as an example also I've got
some money from the Civil War
Confederate dollars from the south and
you know what they'll buy over
chick-fil-a right nothing because no one
places trust in that denomination
anymore in that form of pieces of paper
because they're not currency you follow
me yes same things true I had some
friends of mine that were Special Forces
guy brought me back a few pieces of
Iraqi money with Saddam Hussein's face
on it from
before he was tried and hung right and
before before IROC folded so that money
would buy you things in Iraq prior to
that today it wouldn't buy you anything
there it's monopoly money because
there's no trust has left it does that
make sense yeah the reason that you hear
things like currencies going up or down
the Euro going up or down or the dollar
going up or down or the yen going up or
down is the level of trust that people
place in it into its stability and will
it can I exchange it for goods or
services ultimately becomes worth zero
if no one trusts or no one will accept
it for goods or services that's my
problem with cryptocurrency Bitcoin okay
is that that the trust is only among a
very small group of people and it's very
volatile and the it has been full of in
the last 36 48 months it's been full of
fraudulent transactions and bad deals
and so the vast majority of us on the
outside looking in at that are saying I
have no trust in that very few people as
a percentage of the people in the human
race walking the planet use
cryptocurrency because they trust it I
mean it's one one giant of 1% versus I
was in France this summer and you'd be
amazed
obviously they transact if you didn't
know in the euro and a lot of them take
a dollar take dollars take you know
American dollars and sometimes you know
I can go into a country where they don't
accept the euro but they'll accept the
euro because they know they can still
change those American dollars of those
euros out for goods or services they can
walk down to their bank with a hundred
dollar bill if you're in Paris France
and turn it into a euro turn into 100
euros very very quickly with whatever
the exchange rate is and so the level of
trust is there even though it's not
their actual currency or not our actual
currency
and so you find that you know all
throughout if you do international
travel where you have valid currencies
but the problem with the cryptocurrency
is it's very very risky all of that to
tell you and all of our listeners I
wouldn't put two nickels in that mess
you see why yeah
very risky you're very light another
like very likely learn the expensive
lesson and so at 17 what I would tell
you to do is first let's make sure
you're going to college and you're going
bet free and once you've done that got
that goal with your investing set aside
your dollar saved set aside then the
next goal I would give you if you want
to do some investing is I would use
mutual funds good growth stock type
mutual funds meet with one of our smart
investor pros they can help you open an
account if you want to experiment
starting to learn about that but the
best investment that you can make if
you're going to college is in you and
that's you graduating debt-free that's
the best investment in a degree that
actually has a marketplace use not left
handed puppetry or something but um that
that kind of thing so we're going to
lean in that's your best investment but
if you want actually play in with
investing single stocks are very risky
to nowhere near as risky is something
like a cryptocurrency but it's all
currencies always based on trust hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh